foreign
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
I am uh you know it's Thanksgiving
coming up here uh I believe this show
will be coming out before Thanksgiving
uh and you guys I hope you're
celebrating with nice little uh lovely
family members and all that stuff and
close friends and remember don't call it
friendsgiving because that's annoying
just it's just Thanksgiving with friends
right so uh you can do that and that's
beautiful Christmas is coming up
um before we get into that though I will
be in uh different cities christilia.com
uh San Diego January 7th two shows
Portland Oregon Seattle Washington
Lakeland Jacksonville Florida
lakelandville Lakeland Florida
Jacksonville Florida and Daytona San
Antonio Sugarland Texas New Orleans
Providence Rhode Island New York New
York Chicago Kansas City Missouri
there's a bunch of different ones
Midland Texas all the way through
Minneapolis and Austin and Boise Jesus
I'm doing a lot Cincinnati Ohio uh and
then I'll be also I'm doing dates even
in the Brea Brea Improv so go to
chrysalia.com uh and get your tickets
and uh you can get your merch too for uh
for Black Friday and all that going on
uh we got deals and Deals we got flat
that flannel that came out that looks
hot for the [ __ ] fall crystalia.com
go to merch
um
get some merch makes great gifts for
[ __ ] holidays too
um and we even have gift cards you know
what I mean so uh it's pretty pretty
[ __ ] silly to have gift cards but we
got gift cards
um I do hope that you're with loved ones
I always hope you're with loved ones
okay I always hope you're with loved
ones being with loved ones is absolutely
amazing you don't get to choose uh who's
in your family so I get it if you're not
with them during Thanksgiving but also I
hope you're with them and also if you're
not with them and you don't want to be
with them I hope you're with [ __ ]
beautiful friends or you made a little
family of your own like I did making
families as dope as [ __ ] right people
just make people it's crazy
really really makes you realize how
small we are on this Earth though when
you think about how many people are in
this world right there's like seven
billion and that's way too many I mean
you've ever been to Costco
how many people are in there
45 70. I don't know how many employees
are working at Costco at once 20 40. I
don't know Costco's so [ __ ] big Ikea
how many people are on Ikea at once how
many people are in Ikea at once
a hundred I have no idea they sell
Swedish meatballs there that's
absolutely [ __ ] insane to sell
meatballs and also sell parts to
Furniture
disgusting and both of them are equally
as that uh uh equally as um
uh wet your appetite is equal because
the Swedish meeples are absolutely
disgusting at Ikea
um also yellow and blue together
absolutely looks [ __ ] terrible and
You Know It uh unless you're the ram
so
welcome to congratulations we love
having you here
um I really appreciate you guys I'm very
grateful Thanksgiving is upon us
you know we've done a lot of
Thanksgiving episodes here at
congratulations maybe three or four
we've done a lot of different episodes
here congratulations you know this is
like a 200 900 episode and uh I really
started thinking what is Thanksgiving
because I don't really know what the
[ __ ] it is I know people came to America
and like slaughtered some Indians and
and pretended it was like not that and
they wear belts on their hats and uh you
know which is weird right to have a
[ __ ] Buckle straight on your forehead
you dumb dumb idiots but uh some of
those guys were our ancestors I guess
and Canada and America celebrates
Thanksgiving now they do it differently
right Canadian Thanksgiving is in
October I think and uh Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving is in November
so I thought I'd Google Thanksgiving
because you don't ever really do the
simple [ __ ] but you have to if you're a
dad right
like Calvin asked me stuff that I don't
even think about
that I know the answer to but I haven't
thought about it in [ __ ] 40 years
now I learned about what Thanksgiving is
but if somebody were to say what is
Thanksgiving I would just be like it's
in November and we eat turkey and
stuffing
and argue with your family
so
I Googled it what is Thanksgiving and
why do we celebrate it now I just
Googled Thanksgiving and that was the
first question that comes up which means
it's a bunch of dum-dums
it's a bunch of dum-dums in the world
not just me it's a bunch of dum-dums
not just well not in the world even
though they are in the world because
America is the micro to the macro of the
world but in America it's a bunch of
dum-dums because that's the first thing
that was Googled when you Google
Thanksgiving now they could be Ukrainian
they could be
they could be from Africa they could be
from
China
they could be for penguins from
Antarctica Googling this I guess that
could be why it pops up but mostly it's
probably Americans thinking wait what is
it again so it's a bunch of Dum Dums
Thanksgiving Day annual national holiday
in the United States and Canada is
celebrating the Harvest and other
blessings of the past year
pretty General pretty vague and seems
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] reason to
slaughter a bunch of Indians but
Americans generally believe that their
Thanksgiving was modeled on a 16-21
harvest Feast shared by the English
colonists pilgrims of Plymouth and the
Wampanoag people those are the Indians
right
now that seems like a very nice glossed
over version of what Thanksgiving is
Thanksgiving is a national all right
um
oh look at this
Canada
uh
wait hold on Thanksgiving is a national
holiday support on various dates in the
United States Canada Granada St Lucia
and Liberia um weird one to throw in
there at the end and it began his day of
giving thanks for the blessings of
harvest and of the proceeding year okay
cool yeah Thanksgiving cool similar name
Festival holidays occur in Germany and
Japan wow imagine Thanksgiving in Japan
just showing up and just
[ __ ] mukbanging it
is that racist
um let's go to uh the Wikipedia what is
the true here we go
what is the true meaning of
look at this
1637 is the true origin of Thanksgiving
since the Massachusetts Bay colonies
Governor John Winthrop declared a day to
celebrate
Colonial soldiers who had just
slaughtered hundreds of Pico men women
and children that is now Mystic
Connecticut K got so sad
um
look at this the real history
the true story behind the activity is a
bloody one and some people say it's time
to cancel the holiday well of course
they do right
I have a buddy Mitchell Jones and he
eats Pizza on Thanksgiving because he's
like [ __ ] that [ __ ] they slaughtered so
many people
it has turned into a time of family and
food it really goes to show you though
what time heals all right
like now it's just we were like yes
Thanksgiving when it was in actuality
was like so you never know uh what
people will morph the Holocaust into in
uh you know 300 years it could just be
like you know
yeah [ __ ] you know
it could be Jews giving coming up soon
and you don't even know about it and
then the people are like you know they
killed a bunch of Jews and it was a
Hitler was like this guy and people are
like yeah don't ruin my [ __ ] [ __ ] I
want to eat stuffing
um
Thanksgiving is in the U.S is
traditionally a time for family and food
American sculptures and typically learn
that [ __ ] uh Story Goes friendly this is
the story friendly American Indian local
swooped in to teach the struggling
colonists how to survive and what the
Europeans called the new world then
everyone got together to celebrate a
feast in 1621 that's what I learned and
as a kid
I remember the pictures of the guy with
the [ __ ] belt on his hat and another
dude in the headdress sharing a turkey
leg I remember that one of them was
holding a musket the other one was
holding a bow and arrow at ease a spear
at ease and the Indian kid was playing
with the colonialist I remember it
I remember that mural I remember people
painted mirrors I remember painting a
mural
on a king's grocery store window as a
freshman I was good at Art there were
other but no not a freshman because I
was already in Los Angeles I was in
let's see
[ __ ] a young grade and the other
fifth graders were killing it and they
asked me to do it because I was a good
artist whatever uh I painted Kings my
mom was real happy dude I painted King's
uh the window of kings and my mom was
really happy that I did it when we drove
by and it felt really good that I did it
and uh so go eat that [ __ ] all right
[ __ ] man I felt good and it was
cute all right I was about
eight years old or 10 years old and I
painted the [ __ ] out of the side windows
at the king's grocery store in New
Jersey all right near the movie theater
so go [ __ ] yourself all right
yeah sometimes I did things that made me
feel good and I've got a heart I'm like
the Grinch but also my heart grows at
the end of that movie
uh and then one time I took a break from
eating eating took a break from painting
and I was with a dude that was older and
we were eating at the Cozy end and we
were eating and then I I undid the salt
and uh I put the uh
um what do you call it the tissue in the
salt and put it over the holes so you
couldn't tell that it was clogged and I
screwed it back on and I left it there
and then the older kid was like you like
messing with people huh and I was like I
don't know yeah he was like
so I went and never forgot it
um and I think about it all the time
because again had to uh Taylor ham and
eggs
uh one time my mom yelled at me instead
of my brother uh because we got in
trouble my brother did something she
goes Christopher
and I said I didn't do it she's like oh
Matthew I mean and I was like now you
got to yell at him she's like no it's
over and I got I felt slighted dude
that's life anyway I don't mean to you
know digress let's get back into this
Thanksgiving thing dude I remember that
mural is what I'm saying I remember that
mural
wow Thanksgiving 2021 was the 400th
anniversary of that first American
Thanksgiving but in reality
this is in The Insider
they lie a lot but this is but in the
reality Thanksgiving feasts pre-date
Plymouth and the peace celebrated that
day was tenuous
the real story do you think I could do
that I could actually do books like that
the real story behind the holiday is so
dark in fact that some people are
rethinking how they celebrate the
holiday
or whether they should at all
I'm turning into the dude from [ __ ]
uh Dateline
so that wasn't the first they're saying
it was in 1619 according to National
Geographic and National Geographic
doesn't lie you know how they don't lie
because they show pictures of people
with the long necks and the [ __ ] the
the gold things that stretch the [ __ ]
out and the and the saucers in the
[ __ ] the African tribes and the
sauces and the bottom lips
and they [ __ ] they [ __ ] each other
and and they're they're mating dance is
this
you ever see that that African tribe
with their mating dances like this
I'm not even lying that's what it is
they just Chuck his teeth having really
nice teeth it's really sexy I guess that
they just go
it's like the most insecure mating dance
but dude they the dude see that and they
get [ __ ] you know bracket Geck and
then slide in that wetness because the
chicks are like
that's what they do it's not even I'm
not lying look it up
that's some African tribe [ __ ] and I'm
you know honestly I'm all for it dude I
can't think of anything that would turn
me on more than a woman just going
for no reason if she had nice teeth do
not being dead serious all good got
problems with dead serious no I don't
have problems how about that I do have
problems but that's not one of them
because that would mean that I was
racist I'm not racist that's what
African tribes do if you have a problem
with what me and African tribes do then
you're racist dude if you're upon what I
do with that because that's what African
tribes do so you're racist if you're mad
at me for that
um
but anyway uh 1619 they're saying now is
the real first Thanksgiving uh and the
meal was probably a little more than
some oysters and ham thrown together so
disgusting could you imagine a worse
meal than ham and then also oysters son
healthy
but it wasn't processed back then so
decades before that Spanish settlers and
members of the siloi tribe broke bread
in Florida with salted pork yum dude
garbanzo beans
and a mass oops uh in 1565 I mean how
far back does this goddamn go start with
the beginning dude
I don't like when [ __ ] things are
like hey this is what it wasn't and
neither was this and neither was this
this is what it was started
where it starts
how far back we going dude our modern
definition of Thanksgiving revolves
around eating turkey
nice dark meat is popping white meat is
even more popping if it's not dry if
it's dry dark meat is more popping
but this is more of an occasion for
religious religious observance in past
centuries okay fine
the here we go the pilgrims would most
likely consider their sober 16 23 day of
prayer and first uh for the first actual
Thanksgiving for the first year
Massachusetts blog you know what dude
here we go
the enduring holiday was
erased from our Collective memory
what happened between Wham panag and the
English generation later okay so
wow
uh
so Masa site this is important guys we
got this is American history baby the
wampanog Paramount Chief allied with the
English settlers of Plymouth was
established and fought with the
newcomers against the French and other
local tribes
but the alien Alliance became strained
over time
as a thousands more English colonists
moved to Plymouth taking over more land
yes see authorities are sort of
controlled over most aspects of wimpug
wempanog life yeah a study published
okay oh wait there was it
a study published in a journal
quaternary science reviews estimated
that disease has already reduced the New
England indigenous population by 90
Jesus Christ that's the first covet
uh they needed to get vaccinated
they got it they called it Indian fever
which definitely would be racist now at
this point I mean you couldn't even
[ __ ] mention uh China
when it had to do with covet otherwise
you were
um
this is crazy so they just killed the
the wampanog Warriors responded with
raids and the New England Confederation
of colonies declared war in 1675 so they
were there for a bit the war was bloody
and devastating each
so really there was a Thanksgiving and
then what happened was
there it got a little the people who
lived there got a little bit pissed off
and I understand that dude they're like
they were like the the the colonists
were like the you know the Mother-in-law
or the [ __ ] you know the cousins that
won't they're like Yo dude why don't you
stay at my place
yeah stay at it for a little bit and
then they do and then they're eating
your [ __ ] and you're like you didn't
really put the uh the stuff back it's
fine but just next time put it back and
they're like oh sh my bad dude I fell
asleep right after and you're like okay
cool
and then later on that happens again and
you're like excuse me colonists that
live here in my place uh it's getting
out of control I'm getting pissed off
and then it led to fisticuffs really but
it led to very violent fisticus because
if you're in an open area and this [ __ ]
is going on and we're not talking about
your house but we're talking about land
then you get really really really
involved you're like this is my
Birthright right I didn't just build
this house but I me and my family we
have been here since the dawn of time
and you're just going to come in here
with all your buckles and [ __ ]
and you're gonna [ __ ] try to take it
from us yeah you got guns but dude we go
crazy
yeah you got crazy but dude have you
ever heard a scalp taken
oh I know you got [ __ ] that'll put us on
our backs real quick but how about this
I got [ __ ] that'll put you on yours
slowly
see that's what I would have been like
if I was an Indian
somebody encroached in my territory it's
all good yeah yeah yeah yeah break some
[ __ ] Wings off eat it go ahead have
some wine look at that hey chill out by
the campfire I got a tent that's Barely
Used over there and check out that
wigwam
but hold up though
it's been a month so now what you're
pulling your weight
so now what you're holding out there and
I don't mean [ __ ] hot I mean Harwin
that meant a whole different [ __ ] back
then
what's going on hey did you [ __ ] my wife
no I asked my wife about it and she said
you [ __ ] her in the wigwam
so now I'm getting pissed off because
you're encroaching and also I've been
here [ __ ]
so now what do we do oh you got guns
though oh [ __ ] you could end my life
real quick me as the Indian goes like
this
[Laughter]
I'll put you on your back real slow
we've got dull tomahawks
we've got bows and arrows you know how
many have to hit you before you get
we're not that good of a shot oh we got
[ __ ] clumsy guys in our Squad
oh [ __ ] hey Pilgrim we got clumsy guys
in our tribe
we'll shoot you up near the shoulder
oops
we'll shoot you in the back of the calf
whoops
ah did that graze your rib cage whoops
try 40 of those
and then
I'll scalpia
and then
I'll collect them
right because Indians would just carry
scallops around like don't [ __ ] with me
so you end my life quick but you
I'm crazy
hey guys we're gonna take a little break
and talk about diet smoke all right you
love THC You're Gonna Love diet smoke
all right all of diet smokes products
are guaranteed to give you that
beautiful buzz you know that nice smooth
Buzz that smooth jazz buzz you know what
I'm talking about and that's what you've
been looking for no prescription no
awkward conversation no sketchy weed
deals you don't even need to go to a
store you just decide you want THC they
ship it right to your door they got all
these uh they got Delta 9 THC Delta
eight THC they got CBD this here
is pure CBD all of diet smokes products
are made from American grown hemp that's
right America meaning they're all
federally legal and each product has a
lab test result for potency and safety
diet smoke just released several new
flavors and strength and uh and
strengths like Blackberry yum apple
cider mmm and you gotta try it all right
I've never heard of Edibles that taste
this good and uh one last thing okay
they guarantee 100 satisfaction or your
money it's refunded back to you you
literally can't miss with diet smoke
alright so if you're ready for that
perfect high head over to dietsmoke.com
and use code congrats for 20 off your
entire order get whatever you want it's
20 off must be 21 and older to order
back to the show
crazy crazy
uh yeah so I don't know it's crazy
though because of Thanksgiving and
because the call you know
the uh the people they had that war now
we all exist so it's a bit weird right
it's a bit weird to be like yo
Thanksgiving is [ __ ] because it was
Bloodshed but then also it's why we're
here so in a way you kind of have to
give thanks
even though it sucks for the people that
aren't here right I guess there's a lot
less Indians because of it but and now
and then Americans are like we'll just
give them casinos I guess every now and
then if it's on their land [ __ ] it
just give them have a look yeah that's
the best part yeah give the Indians
casinos where more white people show up
more disrespectful white people show up
just coughing all over their [ __ ]
land just sitting down fat as [ __ ]
pulling this
yeah I've never been to a casino too
where I didn't see a few people with
only one arm
like for some reason that is one arm
City dude when you go to a
um
Casino
all you got to do is look around a
little bit and you'll see people with
less limbs than normal I don't know what
it is about you know they really want to
press their luck but they can only press
it with one arm it's just crazy because
that is
very interesting and that go go now if
you're at a casino right now listening
because your congratulations look around
do you see that guy there that's the guy
I'm talking about how about that
you got [ __ ] couples old ass couples
just pulling the [ __ ] levers just
pulling that lever just waiting for 30
G's to roll out or whatever 5gs
I don't know man
it's weird what the world has come to
right but you know what can I say I'm a
nihilist
I'm an ALICE but I'm also hoping for the
best like I said I'm the Grinch with the
small heart but also it's growing it's
at the end of the movie I feel like I'm
not at the end of my movie I'm in the
middle you know that's a great up so
every now and then I have an emotional
time in my life like if I break down and
cry which I do sometimes full disclosure
don't like breaking down and crying but
it's also necessary sometimes I do that
I wipe my tears and I go like this that
was a tremendous First Act because it
ain't over [ __ ]
it ain't over it J I'm just getting
started right
whenever anyone happens my heart gets
broke I fall down to pick myself up and
I [ __ ] wipe those tears away I go
like this well that was a phenomenal
First Act what about you got it might be
hard dude are you wiping away your tears
yup well that was a [ __ ] phenomenal
First Act
and then it's me just Out outdoors just
drinking coffee meeting people having a
good time buying a suit you know
because life gets hard man especially
during the holidays you ever deal with
that seasonal depression [ __ ]
dude that seasonal depression AKA
depression
dude
out to lunch
get out I wonder what OJ's life is like
right now for real I'm honest like being
dead honest like right now what does he
do for Thanksgiving
who's around him because people love
people people love everyone has people
that love them right and here's the
thing he was acquitted but also
he was
assumed that he did do it and he just
got off off a technicality or some [ __ ]
because Johnny Cochran was like you know
you can't arrest this black dude
I think that was actually what he said
you can't arrest this black dude see bro
and uh one fire literally is leaving
leaving the studio right now in the
middle of it so disrespectful one fire
but he says yeah he said he had a
meeting what could be more important
than this [ __ ] award-winning
Network TV show
um but yeah so OJ uh yeah uh I don't
know some people think it was his son if
you ever look at that look I have no
conspiracy theorist but I will say this
dude if Calvin committed a crime like
that no he didn't it was me
it was me that did it
same DNA because that's my DNA oh no no
no no it wasn't him it was me dude I
tell you right now it was me you know
how that song I want a man on a counter
it wasn't me I make this song [ __ ]
you're starting to stabbed her in the
fur in the [ __ ] solar plexus it was
me that's how it goes
yes I'm joked her in the living room
he gave us so much racing
laughs
just uncut her in the test it was me
that was me
uh
uh there he was just stabbing air all in
the back and in the front
there he was just choking her neck and
you can see the ligament ligatures
um
yeah dude
but what's his life like man he's on
Twitter popping off right I don't know
if he does Instagram it's crazy what do
these guys do
how do you live that way I guess you got
to keep living right
I guess you just got to keep going you
got to keep putting one foot in front of
the other it's [ __ ] actually insane
it's actually insane right
because I think OJ probably thinks he
didn't do it
remember that [ __ ] when he drove and
people are like remember when he
remember when he drove away
and in the Bronco
and people are like oh he didn't if he
did if he wasn't guilty he wouldn't
drive away [ __ ] all that dude [ __ ] all
that I do not agree with that I don't
agree with that at all
our cowlings drove him right he didn't
do it
so what about that what was he guilty of
he was guilty of driving
he was guilty of taking his friend and
just [ __ ] driving into the sunset
man OJ had the gun I would have pulled
that trigger I'll tell you man
he's a stronger dude than I am I would
have pulled that trigger maybe that's a
running back in him dude no I could go
another yard not me dude I go no more
yards Bang
Ling looks back oh [ __ ]
I don't mean to get so serious but Jesus
Christ [ __ ] all that man
uh
that was crazy I remember watching that
on the little TV
um
in uh
yeah in in the millets uh kitchen
and they finally pulled him over OJ and
uh I wonder what his life's like you
have to find some real acceptance man
because I saw somebody once that was uh
uh that uh there's a clip of O.J walking
on the street and someone was like hi OJ
it's really nice to meet you let me just
shake your hand and he [ __ ] and he's oh
hello and he shook her hand and she said
yeah I've never actually shook a hand
with a murderer before thanks and he
goes oh okay oh okay you know
crazy what if he didn't do it wow
I feel like in hundreds of years in
hundreds of years we're going to be able
to get DNA
from people's bodies
no matter how old they are like
decompose whatever Bones and [ __ ] you
take a little bit you stick it in a
program and I think in hundreds of years
maybe a thousand years you will be able
to see all of their thoughts that's what
I think and you will be able to see uh
digitally what they've done and I think
we're going to realize that so many
people did some [ __ ] [ __ ] that
I mean dude the human race is just you
know deplorable but I'll tell you what
dude sore lizards
sore lizards
so at least we have houses that's all
I'm saying
um
yeah man
whatever shout out to OJ and [ __ ] uh
on Thanksgiving
uh
yeah
I don't know
it's pretty crazy
hope everyone's with their family I want
a [ __ ] Nick Cannon family is what I
want
just a big [ __ ] Nick Cannon family
kid guy's got 11 kids
more
another 12th one I thought this was the
11th one he's got 12 kids dude Jesus
what's the oldest one and what's the
youngest one this guy was just popping
him out different wives right this next
one is like the third or fourth child
with her
um so he's got a few baby moms
um that's the kind of [ __ ] I want to
hold army man those Thanksgiving must be
popping but the problem is having more
than like [ __ ] three kids is that one
of them is going to end up hating you
that's the thing you could have two kids
and work it out you have three kids work
it out you guys are getting four or five
the dynamic changes right I loved having
one brother because everything that I
loved I could share with one other
person that I loved and it was beautiful
the connection is amazing if you watch
my podcast Lifeline with my brother you
can tell we love each other
you know we got each other's back no
matter what and that's a beautiful thing
Kristen has her brother it's just
one-on-one and that's a beautiful thing
and that's not taking anything from
somebody with three kids or you got two
or three siblings or whatever I think
that's great too but then you got the
outlier sibling right like you got the
two kids and then the one other one or
the three kids and then the one other
one right and the one other one is
always the one that's like yeah I don't
know if I can make it thank this
Thanksgiving I gotta do a lot of work
and also secretliness had I don't really
like coming in anything you know I'm in
Massachusetts now or whatever
I don't know if I could just be doing
that [ __ ]
um come in and drop in my family I got a
family and it's like you know so there's
something to be said for a one-on-one
[ __ ] and I know if you're a
one-on-one if you're two siblings I know
you feel it now if you're twins all bets
are off you're [ __ ] that's it if you
have twins that's it
because if you have twins and then
another kid later that other kid's
[ __ ]
he doesn't have telepathy like you two
do
you punch one twin the other twin feels
it
the other is like I don't you know I
don't what do I do you guys look the
same and you are the same in me I'm just
Kevin
that's sad as [ __ ]
if I was the brother of two twins do you
know what I would be the most successful
Warlord
straight up I'd have deeper issues and
problems they would have telepathy
together so I would work on being a
[ __ ] warlord and I'll tell you what I
wouldn't be a good one not that there
are many good Warlords
but I would be the most disrespectful
bloodiest warlord of all time and it's
all my parents fault for having me
because they had twins too and they
should have stopped right there so now
guess what Mom and Dad you get a warlord
[Music]
you get a warlord you get a warlord you
get a warlord reach under your seat
that's a warlord for you
you get a warlord is a great title
um it's also the Thanksgiving episode so
it's kind of odd but whatever
you get a warlord the Thanksgiving
episode is what it's called
uh yeah man the bloodiest warlord that's
what I'd be because I tell you man it's
I having Matt growing up was absolutely
amazing
I told him this on Lifeline but I uh I
put a [ __ ] ticking uh a loud there
was a watch that I had in my bedroom and
I put it under his in his pillow
and it was ticking any and and and I
forgot I did it earlier on in the day
and I was like this could be annoying
for him when he goes to sleep and then
my dad and then my I hear him from the
other room my my brother dad what the f
can you come here you go there and then
I hear my dad in the other room just
like I don't [ __ ] hear it I don't
talk about that I don't care I don't
know what I'm saying and I was like oh
are they doing the [ __ ] thing with
the watch and they don't know about it
so I walk in and I was like what's going
on and my brother said my pillow's
ticking
and I was like what and he's like no and
my dad's like no it's not you know my
dad's [ __ ] now at this point is a
little hard of hearing but back then he
probably was just that's when we figured
it out is when I threw a [ __ ] Swatch
in my brother's pillowcase I remember I
was like it's ticking and my dad's like
no it's not I don't hear it
and then I go oh man I did this I'm
sorry I thought it would be funny and it
was for a little bit and I took the
watch out and that's like and then my
dad said why'd you put a watch in this
[ __ ] pillowcase and I literally was
like for this reason it's hilarious
to have hilarity in Sue
what do you mean why we're all here this
is the answer
um
so yeah I did that family shit's awesome
dude how hilarious [ __ ] is awesome if
it's awesome if it's not it's [ __ ]
harrowing
um
but yeah to have 12 kids Nick Cannon to
have 12 kids it's funny to that his last
name is Canon and he's and he's
basically just shooting kids out of his
dick uh
um
Cannon
I don't know man it's wild to have 12
kids
what's up with that huh it's just wild
it's also a bit wild to have one like I
was talking to a guy yesterday who had
one kid and he's like you know a
freshman in high school right now and I
was thinking about how it would be to
give like if I only had Calvin to Give
All My Love to him
I would be a wreck every day like I
would be the most overbearing if you
have other kids you could spread out the
overbearingness
you understand
but I would be so worried like say
Calvin wants to play football I go great
that's it okay you're gonna get [ __ ]
concussed you're the only one I got
because a little bit I'm like the tutors
dude
a little bit I believe in like my
bloodline needs to live forever a little
bit I know it's 2022 it doesn't really
matter and what's in a bloodline what's
in a name it doesn't really matter we're
all people and the World's Gonna explode
soon
the World's Gonna it's not even gonna
explode people worry about the world
exploding shit's so [ __ ] up the
World's Gonna implode like before we
even die we're gonna see the [ __ ] the
waves and the and the and the and the
mountains just suck Us in and and dude
with my luck the world's gonna [ __ ]
you know
implode and I'm gonna see like it's
gonna be like as it comes through and as
the world concaves I'm gonna start
seeing like you know the San Fernando
Valley and then and then like Glendale
California and it's gonna be imploding
Inward and like you know obviously
whatever the opposite of where I am
right now is like Israel or some [ __ ] is
going to be way in the distance I won't
be able to see that but on the sides
I'll see [ __ ] concaving in and like
right before I die I'll [ __ ] uh I'll
get i'll get like smashed with Whitney
Cummings house or some [ __ ] and my last
thought will be like ah yeah a [ __ ]
course you know and uh
so that's what's gonna happen is like
the world's just gonna implode right
but uh
yeah if you've got one kid I don't know
how you [ __ ] give all of your love to
one
person
it's got to be also special in a way
right
it's got to be also beautiful in a way
because right now it feels beautiful but
Calvin's two and a half
you know the more kids that we have
uh the more
I I maybe I'm looking at it wrong
actually maybe I'm looking at it wrong
you know what I bet I am looking at it
wrong I bet because right now I'm
thinking we've got all the love to I
[ __ ] dude I figured it out man I
figured it out without even having more
kids here's the deal I
I
thought
I should have known this man
I thought everyone has the amount of
love
that they could possibly access
ingrained into them at Birth but that's
not what it is dude
your heart grows it expands
and I know this because when I had
Calvin I didn't know I could love
something so much so having more kids
after that it doesn't mean my love for
Calvin's going to dilute it means I'm
gonna have that much love for the others
as well and thus more love in my heart
oh we [ __ ] figured it out he's a real
person and it took him he took the long
way but he absolutely became a real
person
he takes the long way sometimes because
walking the path isn't linear he sees
the top of the mountain he tried to
climb it but really what he should have
done is Twist he's all the way to the
top he took the long way folks
and sometimes with the twisty ways he
realized wait I've been here before
because he wasn't rising at all but
that's okay because it was all part of
the journey and it took the long way
folks
[Music]
we love it dude
it's okay life's about figuring it out
and I will tell you this dude this
podcast
helps me figure things out and I know it
also is there for you too sometimes I
see you guys sometimes you come up with
tears in your eyes and you say thanks
for being there dude I am there I'm
there I'm sorry you're going through
that that tough time but I'm here for
you right here you could hear me you
could see me right now I don't know you
you're somewhere in Tulsa and yes I will
be in Tulsa in May
you can get tickets at chrysalia.com
you know
I'm gonna be in Midland Texas I'm going
to be in Springfield Missouri I don't
even know where the [ __ ] those places
are but if you want to see me in the
flesh you can get tickets at
christalia.com I digress where your
merch get it at crystalia.com this isn't
about the money though
I'm here for you you can watch this
podcast for free or you can pay for it
on patreon patreon.com crystallia but
this isn't about the money this is about
me being here for you
because I am
and guess what I am whether you like it
or not
because I'm going to keep doing this
[ __ ] show
until we're all sitting pretty in the
tall grass
outside of a log cabin sharing ideas
just before the world implodes
I don't know man
it's just how it is
I'm sorry little kids but I'm a killer
clown today anyway we bring it up it
soundboard heavy because it's the
Thanksgiving episode but you know this
episode is one of the better ones we've
had in a long time to be brutally honest
with you guys we're taking you out to a
roller coaster of emotions and there's
still some left there's still some left
dude uh
yeah you know I was thinking about this
man a lot of people talk to me about my
podcast when they come up to him in the
streets I don't know how long I'm gonna
do this [ __ ] podcast man I have no
idea
is this [ __ ] Gonna Last for [ __ ] 10
years or am I gonna be like all right
enough's enough I don't know how long I
could keep bullshitting you
[ __ ]
I don't know how long I could keep
talking about my day and have you
[ __ ] keep listening and you
still come back you do numbers fluctuate
we go up and down but you keep coming
back I love you for it
foreign
stopped doing the tour reports because I
was like do people even like this and
then I [ __ ] uploaded the last tour
report and I made it 11 minutes and
everyone is like oh no we're [ __ ] why
is this one only 11 minutes I'm like
[ __ ] man you want them to be long
I'm insecure that's why
but it's all good
what did you guys ever do
um
on Thanksgiving
you're gonna be with families do you
want to be with family or do you not
want to be with families
because do you hate your family
if you hate your family I'm your family
um look at these
the the
disgusting thing about Thanksgiving is
anytime somebody makes turducken
National Thanksgiving turkey
presentation President Ford pardoning a
turkey at you know it's like the pardon
what does that even mean parting a
turkey like they're not going to cut its
[ __ ] head off
is that what that means what does it
mean to Pardon a turkey
you don't know he doesn't know who the
[ __ ] what does it even know
let it go back go into the wild yeah
that's what you'd think it is
just disgusting dude
turkey eating competitions and [ __ ]
gross any eating competitions are gross
national Thanksgiving turkey
presentation
um uh what is turkey bowling turducken I
know what that is Turkey
bowling
are you [ __ ] me
a sport in which
oh my God turkey bowling is a sport in
which
uh is based on ordinary bowling a frozen
turkey such as a bowling ball and 10
plastic bottles of soft drinks or water
or bowling pins the turkey has boiled
down a smooth surface for example ice or
a soap covered sheet of painters plastic
I mean so specific using a bar of soap
it is commonly associated with
Thanksgiving I mean I mean what dude
turkey bowling is popular in minor
league ice hockey in the United States
and kind of imagine you [ __ ] die
and like a superior species just keeps
chucking your body down an aisle
like they're doing that with your dad
you know what I'm saying
or did do what you're with your cousin
it's just [ __ ] flailing all around
with soapy water just into some [ __ ]
diet right
like that's so [ __ ] up
like just eat the turkey dude
although turkey's dad who [ __ ] cares
and I always said throw me when I'm dead
who gives a [ __ ]
throw me when I'm dead use me dude I'll
take the heat when I die just use me
cart my body around and do some crisp
bowling do some turkey bowling with me
stick some feathers in my eyes I don't
give a [ __ ] man
you know people are like oh like my mama
was always like at my funeral I want you
to play that Neil Armstrong's not Neil
Armstrong what the [ __ ] is it was he the
singer or was he the uh the astronaut
who's the Armstrong
Louis Armstrong yeah uh What a Wonderful
World that one she's like I want you to
play that song and I'm like man when I
die play whatever the [ __ ] you want I'm
not there
I'm I'm there but I'm not there you know
what I mean I'm dead
play [ __ ]
together
I play that dude and do the Macarena as
a matter of fact put me on a marionette
[ __ ] and make me do the Macarena
I just my tongue coming out
I'll give a [ __ ] and don't put me in a
suit either
leave me in my clothes
it's so I hate putting on a suit you're
gonna put one on when I'm dead [ __ ] you
just keep my chains on man
bury me and my Wimbledon shits
oh they didn't do anything to us and
don't put makeup on me bro what my
Jeffree Star
just let me be white as [ __ ] mouth all
open just
leave my hands all contorted rigor
mortis sets in let it set when
Rigamortis sets in set it and forget it
like Ron Paul peel
and what do we do set it and forget when
I'm dead I'm set dude
and don't be all oh move his fingers
right put the [ __ ] formaldehyde in
and keep them nice
the way I make a coffin you know how
they have the [ __ ] bodies in chalk
make the coffin that way
make the coffin this way
and just Place me in nicely like a
[ __ ] like it's operation or like a
puzzle piece that just fits perfectly
like something from Indiana Jones that
once you just slide in it unlocks a
whole nother room and there's like
beautiful gold chalices in it that's how
I want to be done dude
bury me in this Billy shirt man
don't put any extra hair gel I'm done
you [ __ ]
if I feel Rouge coming dude I'm gonna
I'll be I'll be because I'll be astral
projection watching you do it I'll be so
pissed off like God damn it they're
doing it come on man pick up your arm
I'll make it happen dude don't put the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my thing and I swear my
mom's still gonna be like I know he
didn't want it but still put it it's for
everyone else I know do it and I guess I
don't care because I'll be dead but dude
there's something really humiliating
about dying and then that's the time
that everyone puts [ __ ] makeup on you
you know
that's humiliating
you got construction workers just dying
and then you've got people other dudes
just like well let's fix them up a
little bit here we go are you kidding me
this guy
this guy had a hand in [ __ ] making
the Citizens Business Bank across the
street and you're gonna [ __ ] put
makeup on him
on Carl
I used to join the I used to be a part
of this Bank Citizens Business Bank and
uh back when I was like not having any
money I would live like paycheck to
paycheck and I would overdraft like I
didn't give a [ __ ] when I overdraft like
I did it like it was part of it a part
of having a bank account that's how I
overdraft
and I would never think of it I'd be
like well I have [ __ ] 13 left but I
want to buy this thing that's 20
overdraft City I guess I'll pay [ __ ]
30 for the overdraft fee [ __ ] it and I
would do it and I would get overdressed
and and every time Hortensia would call
me
and I knew her a lot because it was a
bank in La Canada and I stayed there for
some reason even though I lived in
Burbank I wasn't in locking out anymore
but I would drive to I would have to
drive there and make a deposit dude and
this was back before like all the
electronic shits would have would go
down with your phone you could deposit a
check and duchy would call me and I
would never pick up and every message
was the same and it would always sounds
like this hello Chris this is Hortense
here from citizensbusiness Bank you need
to make a deposit
and dude
I remember it okay and that's that hello
Chris this is Horton this is Hortensia
from Citizens Business Bank you need to
make a deposit
that's what it was and that's what I did
and every [ __ ] time I would drive
over and make a deposit and I would go
and get it I would go get Georgie's and
I'm gonna go get the sandwich
from Georgie's and one time I I I'll go
get well is this even interesting
whatever it doesn't matter I do what I
want here this is my podcast listen to
it or don't uh and I went to uh
Georgie's and I would always get the
club sandwich just with turkey in it
and no middle bread
I didn't want ham because I don't like
ham because Ham's for suckers dude even
on Thanksgiving I don't eat ham eight
Hand by mistake the other day didn't
like it secretly liked it and then got
pissed off and knew it was ham because
it was uh an Italian sub and some they
don't normally put ham in the Italian
sub he's supposed to put the gabagool
and the [ __ ] uh salami and all this
[ __ ] but the ham was in it and I didn't
know that and I liked the whole thing
and then somebody said to ham was it and
I got pissed off but it's all good man I
don't like ham they tricked me into
eating the ham
and uh
and uh so
what was I saying [ __ ] some some
childhood story oh and then I went to
George's and I would get the thing and
then and then they had to they put the
ham in it and then by mistaken was like
yo there's ham in this and then the
owner got so mad he was like this guy
comes in all the time and he doesn't get
ham you [ __ ] it up and you put the ham
in there and I felt bad for the lady
I think she still works there honestly
did they sell Georgie's I have no idea
it was a great place we would go we
would go to lunch in high school
um oh [ __ ]
I love being on the road man I love
being on the road and doing my shows
I'm very grateful
I'm very happy
well enjoy your Thanksgiving you know
look at this going back to the turkey
building animal rights proponents who
who animal rights of proponents who
oppose the use of animals in sports
claim that turkey bowling is
disrespectful to animals and sends mixed
messages which may encourage violence to
animals or people dude I the the
sometimes the Animal Rights group are
are right but what they get upset about
is is the wrong thing about it
like
it doesn't
encourage violence to animals or people
it's just disrespectful to roll a
carcass
down the aisle where cleaning detergent
is do you know what I mean
it's like
another objection is perceived
disrespect
to the central attribute of Thanksgiving
the all these organizations you know
such [ __ ] in 2003 an upcoming event
for the title of UK great turkey bowling
champion at Manchester Evening News
Arena was protested against by animal
rights campaigners as a result plastic
turkeys were used instead of real frozen
turkey as well
made for probably a worse game I gotta
be honest in 2007 an animal sanctuary
rescued a live turkey which was in a
cage from a turkey bowling event in New
York state wow that's amazing dude
just
[Music]
come on tiptoeing like Ace Ventura
gotta get this turkey out dude before
they bowl with it
dude did they'd be amazing if they
rescued the carcasses
come on if it gets done in the [ __ ]
Frozen it's a booby High one right
because it's frozen and they never had
those In The Middle come on go wrong
side hey wrong side
with the night vision come on
um
there they are okay grab them [ __ ]
there's just me and you I guess we can
only get like three or four
well whatever it's better than nothing
but they're already dead you should have
to [ __ ] up this at the point let's go
and then they go to run and they slip on
the soapy water that they use turkey
bowling in yesterday and they [ __ ]
die and then they're a carcass and then
people use them the next day
at Night Shyamalan [ __ ] or uh what do
you call that Cabinet of Curiosities
whatever that [ __ ] new uh
gamble Del Toro [ __ ] is dude gamer
territoro makes great [ __ ] but but that
series
it's so weird he's trying to do like an
Alfred Alfred Hitchcock thing it's so
boring and he comes out in the beginning
and talks and it's awkward dude
give me the Toro talks and he's just
like and it's so funny too because he
tells the story about what's gonna about
to happen which you never need to know
do in storytelling and then he always
says this one is directed by this guy
and he does that because he's a director
and he wants to give a director to cut
it and that irks me I have problems all
good
gonna talk to a chair and pretend it's
my mom
um
what other animals are in sports by the
way
oh look at all these
protesters cry foul at Turkey bowling
ice hockey bosses were forced everything
plans to Stage the country's First
Circuit bowling
ah boy they called foul you know that's
absolutely incredible
um so I think that uh through the
holidays I'm actually gonna uh
do
um the episodes are not going to be as
long uh I know sometimes I do like an
hour 20 minutes
um and I'm just [ __ ] gonna take time
to [ __ ] hang out with my son and [ __ ]
I'm still gonna do him but uh it's just
the holidays dude and uh family is
important to me
um and I think that uh you're gonna have
to be uh okay with that but I got the
tour reports and all that [ __ ] you
should check those out on my other uh
channels to report uh the Cheyenne one
was good we had a lot of silly goose
times we did some actually that's why I
was thinking about the mission
impossible thing because I did that [ __ ]
over there
um yeah and subscribe to the chat dude
we gotta get to it's 596
000 still we gotta push past it let's do
it we can get 597 what are we at right
now let me look at what we're at right
now
let me look at what we're at right now
um
because I got it on my YouTube Studio
here super cold Studios
oh still 596 581.
it just never
ever stops
subscribe
check and see if you're subscribed as a
matter of fact maybe you aren't even
subscribed and You Think You Are
that'd help too leave a comment in the
algorithm that'll help too and subscribe
to my other channel the crystalia
channel but anyway guys Happy
Thanksgiving if you listen to this on
Thanksgiving have a great Thanksgiving
go to chrislea.com get your merch for
the holidays Black Friday and all that
Cyber Monday we got Deals Deals Deals
and then also
um
you know get good holiday gifts if you
know people are fan we also got gift
certificates man we do it all we do we
do it we do it all my babies and then
also get your ticket to crystal.com I'm
coming to Austin I'm coming to San Diego
Seattle and Portland and all sorts of
places Midland Texas so go to
chrislea.com and uh just peruse well
guys that's the end of the
on YouTube if you want to catch the rest
of the episode The Raw the uncut the
uncensored the un uh
no ads episode go on over to our patreon
patreon.com crystalia and that's what
you can do it's only six bucks to get
the rest of the all of the episodes and
then also the extra episodes that we've
been doing for quite some time now once
a month so there are a ton of them you
can go and watch them right now backlog
uh thank you very much you guys are
great
[Music]
thank you
[Music]